you cannot have innovation or progress
without failure
it doesn't exist
um
and if you truly aren't failing as
you're trying to innovate then you're
probably not pushing very hard because
you haven't broken anything you're
taking you're making very very safe
choices we could never put a person on
the moon without a bunch of rockets
blowing up first like
of course
um uh um i i met a cfo once i asked him
the priorities of the company and he
said efficiency and innovation and i
laughed and said well good luck with
that you know innovation is inherently
inefficient because it requires
experimentation experimentation requires
failure um
much is said about fail fast
i actually
don't like the term that we i think we
overuse the term failure
um
you know and the problem with the word
failure is it's like the word cancer
it's too broad like if you have stage
four liver cancer or you have a mild
melanoma those things are both called
cancer but they are clearly not the same
thing and the same thing is when we hear
the word failure some people think
failure means experimentation but a lot
of people think failure means
catastrophe and so when we tell our
company failure is good fail fast that
literally
scares people
we don't want to fail so i think we need
a new word right we want to avoid
failure failure is catastrophic and it
should be avoided but falling i think we
should encourage you know when a kid
falls off a bicycle we didn't tell them
they failed we tell them they fell and
what do we tell them get back up and try
again so i don't want to tell people
they fail i want to see people they fell
and i want to encourage them to try
again and you know brush off their knees
so i think we should fall and fall often
and i will judge the quality of
innovation not necessarily
by if you fell but how quickly you can
pick yourself back up and try again
what starts to happen is over the course
of time some of the process becomes
calcified and we follow it because we've
just always followed it and nobody
really knows why it's there and all it
takes is one person to say can somebody
explain to me why do we do it this way
and if nobody has an answer
then it's right to be changed or at
least challenged yeah why do we have 14
approvals for hiring one person right
why do we have 14 approvals to hire one
person right exactly can somebody give
me a good reason why we have why we do
it this way
um
well we want to double check we want to
double check meaning you don't trust the
people who are making decisions no we
trust them well then why do you have to
double check them
and all of a sudden the argument falls
apart so if i heard you correctly the
way we prevent this as a 95 000 person
team is to have courage to speak up when
something doesn't make sense
the courage to speak up when something
doesn't make sense but but also to um
allow people who
question something
to give them a a a an open space to feel
heard rather than
defeated you know you know uh litigated
and if they have
legitimate cause to change the process
but there's still fear to like blanketly
change it or you know everywhere because
that might be destructive to let them
experiment on their team with their
group and try something new and if it
works
great
maybe we'll look at it and if it doesn't
work then it's good that's fine too
thank you for testing it for us it turns
out that this process worked well enough
and so um it's it's not just about
speaking out it's also about hearing it
and allowing people to even challenge it
sometimes if they have a better option i
don't like people who challenge things
without a solution this doesn't work
great what should we do well it doesn't
work i got that what should we do
different got it
what should we do and i like people to
bring ideas that's exactly what this
culture circles
effort is all about is giving people the
power
to address their subculture to pilot
ideas that they think will improve our
culture if they work we're going to
scale it we're going to we're going to
do it everywhere it's love diffusion
it's the way exactly you start with the
early adopters let them let them because
they don't mind the imperfections
um you know some of it will come back
automatically like you know interacting
with people we thought it'd be so scary
and difficult but turns out it's okay i
think relearn
is the importance of just sort of being
around people i think some of us
got good at
virtual
and being separated and i think we have
to relearn the importance of you know
having a meeting in person and having a
brainstorming in person the joy of the
of the interaction and interrupting
people you can't interrupt people in
flow
over zoom but you can in a meeting and
it's it's invigorating um i think
unlearn
um
i think unlearn the maybe constant
connection
uh being constantly connected for some
people you know they reported working
more not less during coded in a virtual
scenario learning to turn things off you
know
there was something magical about about
the commute
you know when you had to like go to work
and come home from work it's like it
gets you ready for the day and it helps
you unwind and unwind at the end of the
day and we lost we lost the commute
and you know you start to sort of
want it back a little bit so i think
relearn some of the
some of the stuff that we used to
complain about it maybe wasn't so bad
after all